this [ __ ] argument about jobs lost on
this keystone pipeline
is just as dumb if not [ __ ] dumber
than the than the cheeseburger price
affected by
15 dollar minimum wage this is [ __ ]
dumb number one they they say oh well
you lost
11 million jobs or 10 000 jobs
whatever they're saying they pour a lot
of numbers out of nowhere
number one the 11 million that they're
talking about was estimated
and estimated numbers from start to
finish on this project of how many
permanent
and temporary jobs are going to be
created start to finish so
post during and pre-pipeline
that was an estimate then they this 10
000
number this [ __ ] number is the
estimated and again
another [ __ ] estimated pull straight
out of their ass surely they didn't
overshoot
and oversell how many jobs were gonna be
on this project surely they didn't do
that
to get the permits oh that couldn't have
been the case
they estimated that ten thousand jobs
would be created temporary
temporary jobs and that's in the united
states
well we find out that it was actually a
thousand
so they overshot by ten times that it
was a thousand
temporary jobs that were going to be
lost temporary
jobs temporary and there's only going to
be a
approximately again they're probably
overshooting this by 10 times
35 permanent jobs in the united states
so this this is the argument that
they're going to make to to
to bury this [ __ ] pipe of sludge
underneath important waterways on native
[ __ ] lands in this country
which we all know we all know no matter
how good they build this thing
this [ __ ] is gonna fail and it's
gonna spill
that's how this [ __ ] works that's how it
[ __ ] works
all for maybe 35 permanent jobs in this
country
and people are oh joe biden killed a
thousand jobs i hope you're happy
i hope you're happy well yeah we we are
happy
this is what we voted for we voted for
joe biden to get his [ __ ]
someone to get their head out of their
[ __ ] ass and realize that the
keystone pipeline was not going to be a
big job creator in this country
that is possibly it's possibly
alternative energy
and that industry is where all the jobs
are going to come from and that's maybe
where we should focus our
[ __ ] energy on science
and on real economics and real policy
that will move the country and the
economy forward
which we were doing which we were doing
under the obama
biden administration for eight [ __ ]
years
and then we had the the orange deity
come in
and act like he was just gonna do the
exact opposite
so no your argument about the keystone
pipeline and jobs lost is [ __ ]
dumb and actually if you think about it
at the
at the bare minimum here it's the exact
opposite argument that they make about
15 an hour that's gonna raise the price
of cheeseburgers
so what you're saying is is if workers
have more equity
which would mean more jobs
then that would be a good thing oh but
it's a bad thing for cheeseburgers
good thing for oil pipelines that spill
bad thing for cheeseburgers you people
need to get your [ __ ]
heads out of your asses wake the [ __ ] up
and realize
you dumb [ __ ] are being lied to
you're being [ __ ] lied to
there was not a thousand permanent jobs
lost it wasn't
it was maybe 35 at the most and let me
let me tell you
if they're estimating 35 they're
estimating over
just like they estimated 11 million and
10 000 and a thousand jobs
canada's pissed because it's their jobs
not ours
we're just the [ __ ] playground that
the pipe gets to go through
it doesn't stop here we don't get to
[ __ ] ride the [ __ ] oil train
it goes through us we're an easement you
dumb [ __ ]
that's it and the easement was through
[ __ ] important waterways and native
lands
which was gonna spill important
waterways
so get your [ __ ] head out of your ass
and quit quit with this
head up ass syndrome [ __ ] we're
[ __ ] tired of it
[ __ ] them